[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett and i'm
link this week at the round
table of dim lighting we are exploring
your nostalgic memories because we put
out a prompt
at mythical on twitter so uh be looking
out there if you want
if you want to interact with us and for
us to read some of your
submissions and talk about it the
the prompt that uh we put out into the
world is
what's one thing you could bring back
from childhood
that you wish you could if you would
would you do you
you can't people check it in different
ways and it got us thinking about some
things so we're going to talk about
your childhoods our childhood talking
about some
entertainment practices we're talking
about some toys we're talking about some
school experiences
uh we rounded up some good stuff which
uh
ring that old nostalgia bell you know we
like to ding ding
we like to look we like to look
backwards fondly
because hey we lived it all together man
well i mean
you know i started in first grade i
spent some time alone i had some
girlfriends
and that i got wrapped up with for a
while yep you kind of left me in the
dust
well you could have done the same you
had the freedom to do the same thing
yeah but uh you know i had
maybe even more opportunity to do that
and still didn't take advantage of it i
had a nintendo
i had well so did i had a sega i know
you did
yeah a b and c buttons
i think we were over in the nintendo by
the time you started getting into the
the girls hot and heavy
but uh we'll get into all of that stuff
but
first i just wanted to share um
an experience that when i shared it it's
something that happened to me
something i participated in usually
that's what it is something i can take
credit for
that experience that happened to me but
when i shared it with my family
none of them believed me they didn't
appreciate it no they didn't even
believe that it happened
okay well all right they thought i was
making it up i would
i told i told lily and then
i'm pretty sure she believed me because
i thought i had proof and then
separately
i told christy and lincoln and they
didn't believe me and then when i got
lily to tell them
what i told her it she
turns out i thought she believed me but
she didn't either so now i'm going to
tell you the experience
i'm not going gonna believe you maybe
maybe you won't believe me either
maybe i am lying maybe this is just a
sensational story
that is made up for entertainment and
for some reason you along with my family
and everybody listening will just
say they're gonna do a lot of damage to
the reputation of yourself
and this podcast if you're going to lie
about something that happened to you
because we do not do that sometimes
we're mistaken
some stories are about some things that
happen to us but we never intentionally
lie about anything until right now
potentially okay all right you be the
judge so
you know how my backyard works it's like
this
um pave is pavers
in a patio the whole backyard is a pool
and then a patio there's no lawn back
there
and then neither of us have any grass
you have some fake grass i have some
fake grass you have grass in the front
i have yeah i have lawn in the front but
in the back i just have
you know the pavers go all the way to
this this wall that
is like a pony wall it's like two and a
half feet off the ground
and then there's like this cabling thing
above that you ever try to keep a pony
up there just to see if it would cross
it
i think the pony would stay in because
it's kind of like a fence
and then when you walk close to the edge
which this is
i was i was going to be doing some
grilling you saw something didn't you
and i looked down into my neighbor's
yard below me
so you guys do you know i'm on the hill
and so when my neighbors when i look
down i could i
it's i'm i'm i'm pretty elevated so i
can look down and see like if they've
got if they're outside eating
let's say and they've got a table of
food i'm i'm i'm
at such a height and vantage point that
i could see the whole top of the table
and everything that they're eating
you know if anybody has a bald spot i
can see that i'm looking down on these
people
literally not figuratively i don't even
know them that well but your house is
higher so it makes it i mean
you are kind of also looking down on
them figuratively so the higher the
house on the hill the better right
you want to be on the top row i don't
want to i don't want to say that but i'd
like for you to say it about me
okay the higher the house on the hill
the better you want to be the guy with
the house at the top of the hill
i'm actually you're not all the way up
then you're a target you want to be the
guy
right next to the guy who's at the top
of the hill that's kind of i don't
really look
i go out my front door and then there's
a street and there's people on the other
side so like
no one in their backyard is looking down
at me there's someone
like your neighbor in his backyard can
look over and look down on you but he
really has to get a very it's got to
work
he's got a and it has happened a couple
of times where i'll be in my
you know i like to i like to be scantily
clad in
my backyard because it feels very
private and
um every once in a while let's be honest
i don't know i can't remember his name
he's introduced himself several times
but he'll just be standing up there
hey i'm just like hey and you're naked
i haven't been naked yet i mean i
haven't been naked where i think if he
saw me naked he wouldn't say hey he
would turn around and walk back
i don't know the couple that lives down
below me
um you know it's a totally different
street that accesses their house it's
like uh
we're like backyard neighbors right so
it's like it's kind of a strain and
they're so far down there
you wouldn't even know how to drive to
their house i haven't haven't really had
an interaction with them
i wanted to because they had this huge
tree
in their side yard that basically
it blocked some of my view but starting
with don't get me started with neighbors
trees man
that's a sore subject for me well they
chopped it down
which gave me a better view but it just
seems pretty open
and i'm but i'm not going to hold that
against him and i'm
i guess i'm looking for opportunities to
like you had a problem with the tree and
they cut it down and you're not going to
hold it again so i don't understand the
logic
i had a problem with them cutting down
the tree because i liked it oh you liked
it yeah
because i'm so at such a height that
like i was eye level with the
the middle and top of the tree i felt
like i was in the foliage i was in their
tree yeah i could see like birds at eye
level
it was awesome right big old tree but i
you know i want to mend fences i'm
looking for opportunities i literally
look over
because i'm out there i'm going to start
grilling and then i smell
there's like this like oh it smells good
somebody's grilling out down there and i
look over i have no idea what you're
about to say
and it's one of those girls it's got
it's just like a rectangular grill with
like shish kebabs
going across it like uh
like what i call lulay you know you got
that
you got chicken shish kebab and then you
got the lulay shish kebabs and boy that
stuff smells so good
and the long piece of meat in there yeah
and they're grilling it out
and i look over and i see the guy who
lives in the house he's an
he's an older guy he's probably he might
be 60. before i knew it
i found myself yelling at him
smells good
[Music]
such a redneck had he made eye contact
with you before you said smells good no
big mistake just right off the bat right
now he's good
and he looked up at me and then i said
yeah i didn't think about any of this
ahead of time going totally on instinct
and i'm like
uh throw me a piece of that meat
oh god what is
wrong with you man i said i'll catch it
and i held my hand out like that and
then i looked from him to like
this woman that was standing next to him
to she see what her reaction was
and they were all just kind of like i
guess taken aback
this guy was yelling pieces
of meat i'll catch smells good
and then out of the corner of my eye as
i was surveying how the crowd was
responding to my
you know friendliness i see
a piece of meat flying in the air
okay hold on so you specifically called
for
meat to be thrown at you and then you're
surprised when it happens what is wrong
with you man
i wasn't well yeah i was a little
surprised it was one of those
friendly neighbor things that i just
thought i was saying it's like smells
good
throw me a piece i'll catch it what
doesn't
you didn't catch it so again it was just
out of my periphery
and just like a cat i
just instinctively it wasn't coming at
me it was going far to my left
i lunged over and you know how there's
those
that above the pony wall cement wall
there's like those cables
that prevent someone from like standing
on the pony wall if they're a toddler or
something and then just like careening
over
tumbling all the way down into the
neighbor's yard so
i reached as far as i could i bent over
that
cable because he was throwing it short
he threw it shortened
to his right to my left short yeah and i
reached over
like this and and bent down
and if he had thrown it
even more to the right just
a millimeter i would not have caught it
you caught that snagged it and i did
catch it
and i held it up and i said i got it
and i took a bite out of it it was a it
was a strip of lulay about that long
was it cooked it was cooked i took a
bite out of it and i was like
man that's good and uh
the woman turned to the to the man who
threw it
and said wow that was a really good
throw
and i said no that was a really good
catch
and i took another bite so did somebody
who had already been served
meat who had it on their plate throw it
or did the guy who was grilling throw it
the guy who was grilling through it and
it was a surprise
i was no i yelled and then i was looking
at other people
so i didn't see him actually throw it
and i said to him you know what
i didn't see you throw it i just saw the
meat in midair
and i just happened to reach over and i
was able to they clap
they didn't clap and then what did he
say he didn't say
anything and i ate the meat and i was
like
i was like i was like yeah it was a good
catch and they kind of
laughed a little bit but not really and
then then they just went back to what
they were doing
there was no conversation uh
i was smiling and i was like i might
have said one more thing i don't know
but it wasn't like it
it didn't lead to like a budding
friendship like i thought it would
and i had a little piece of the meat and
i went inside and i just felt like i
needed to tell somebody
and lily was playing video games and i
told lily the story and like i said
i didn't think she wouldn't believe me
especially because i showed her the
piece of meat that i still had
where's a man gonna get a piece of meat
just walking outside so later when i
told lily and lincoln
lily i mean christy and lincoln
they didn't believe me i said ask lily
she saw the piece of meat
and then lily came out later and i was
like tell him what i did and he was like
well dad said that he caught a piece of
meat but like
i don't believe him and i'm like lily i
had the meat in my hand she was like
well i saw something in your hand but
like
you know you could you could have
anything in your hand i was like what no
one believes
so do you believe me no i'd say that for
a second
and then i was like fine no one's gonna
believe me we're sitting out by the fire
pit eating the dinner that i grilled
and their party does it not as good
their party had disbanded by this point
no one was outside
you don't even know this guy's name i
don't know his name he don't know my
name he threw you meat
threw me meat i mean he walked that's
first name basis stuff right i know
man he walked out and i was like there
he is right there
you guys don't believe me and i'm gonna
so i leaned over and i looked at the guy
i was like
hey i just told my family about catching
your meat
and you know what they don't believe me
and he looked up at me and he kind of
he kind of smiled and nodded his head
but there wasn't an audible laugh
and then he grabbed something off of his
girl and he went
back inside he didn't say anything i was
like my family didn't believe me
and he like he didn't say anything you
gotta go
front door this is a front door this is
a knock on the front door
and say hey we got to talk you got to
back me up man you're going to throw me
meat and then deny it
i don't think silence i don't think it's
about him validating your story at this
point i just think it's about
you have to acknowledge this level of
connection that you've made it was cool
man
like i haven't i have i mean like i have
an abrasion on my arm
where where uh look at that well that
doesn't prove anything in fact that's
from the cable now that you're
showing me that it's making me doubt
your whole story like it's a real stuff
you don't want to know it you don't have
to show me scars heroic
catching of meat and i mean he threw the
meat as far as a man could throw a piece
of lulay
it could not have been thrown you do
understand
you do understand what the next stage in
this relationship is
you back to that assert dominant stuff
uh no no this is not this isn't about
you this isn't like your other neighbor
where you have to assert dominance they
put up a fence by the way
like really yeah they can't see me in my
shower anymore
through the window of my shower they
watched the vlog i think they did yeah
this isn't an assert dominant situation
um
this is this is a kinship this is
camaraderie
but you've got to return the meat the
the meat i know i gotta you have to
throw meat to this man
i gotta throw meat to him and you and
then deny it like
i just don't think he's a
conversationalist i think he keeps to
himself
and i come on pretty strong you know i
can't say that again it's definitely
my dad coming out in me you know it's
like hey that smells good throw me a
piece
you know it's just like it's only gonna
go just happens but you know what it
leads to connection
usually you know hey this guy's putting
himself out there he almost killed
himself trying to catch my meat
yeah we have a connection
well i mean i'm not mad i feel like you
you have to you have two options you
could just go
front door and be like we need to talk
about the meat situation
um my family my family doesn't believe
it but
it's really not about that anymore it's
just i feel like i don't even know your
name man
and then see where it goes or equally
valid
and maybe more fun is you just need to
be
you need to grow more you need to be out
there in fact
you need to have meat on the ready it
doesn't even have to come from your
grill
just have some meat on the ready just a
meatball maybe
yeah just one if you see him you run in
you put it in pop it in the microwave
for 30 seconds to meet one meatball
20 seconds it'll warm up you know you're
like i got
i got your meat not his meat or um
i get i i want to return the fat i want
to return the favor
i want to return the flavor oh yes
that's what you say
i want to return the flavor he will not
catch it
uh he's because i mean the f he's cool
that he threw that meat back he's an
older guy
i mean probably can't see the meatball
he might need to be a bigger meatball
isn't it cool that he threw the meat you
know it's like i can't believe he did it
i mean i can't believe i'd rather for
him to give me the silent treatment
having thrown meat my way
that's what they did not throw
because the venn diagram between people
right who will throw
meat after being asked one time yeah and
will not then talk about it later
yeah that that doesn't feel like the
same person
it's it's kind does he feel like we had
some so the connection was so deep
like it's an affair does he feel that
does he feel
shame does he does he feel like he needs
to keep it under wraps do i need to well
he did it in front of 10 people so i
don't think so
maybe but those people weren't impressed
maybe he was ridiculed it was like yeah
they didn't know what to say i would
have collapsed
i just for one i would have clapped if
somebody caught me like that
i mean they definitely think i'm a
redneck right i don't think they know
about rednecks
it was a redneck move wasn't it well
yeah it was but i don't think that's how
they would categorize it what are they
what do you think they think of me
strange what else are they saying
strange and outgoing
they hear you play your music yeah yeah
they probably hate that they have
opinions about that i'm sure
all right well thanks for almost
believing me
yeah yeah to be clear i don't believe
any of it let's get back into childhood
what i do believe is that we've got some
hats for sale
uh the mythical kitchen's got a nice
looking hat i can't remember what they
call this uh
spaghetti spaghetti uh
octopus octa spaghetti squid
[Music]
it's cool though and here's the uh this
is a total quinky dink
i got the feel good mythical morning hat
here which is sort of the dad style hat
in purple and i'm wearing the feel good
oh
nice hoodie because it just feels good
plan it on put it on for that reason
that reason alone mythical.com
make it happen rep your boys let's see
okay uh if you could pick one thing from
your childhood bring back what would it
be
let's get started with theresa dawley
who said two words
school pizza i was so excited about this
because i was thinking
not necessarily school pizza but you
know me and food
you don't have to throw meat at me to
get me excited um
yeah i'm always thinking about food and
i was thinking about the food that i
enjoyed as a as a lad
and i was thinking how could i recreate
some of the things that i enjoyed at the
bowie's creek elementary cafeteria and
square
for us square or really rectangular
pizza
you you call it square pizza call it
square pizza but
i wonder how good it would be if i were
to eat a piece right now would i be like
this is the worst pizza i've ever had
i didn't like it at the time you didn't
like you didn't eat the pizza at the
time
no i didn't like it you didn't even eat
it i didn't even eat it did you ever try
it
yeah i tried it it wasn't horrible but
it was i remember it being
really soft it was so good i would eat
more i would eat other people's who
didn't finish it and it was
rectangular because it was a big sheet
and it fit into the tray it fit into
the section of the tray that was a
rectangular rectangular
shape and they just cut it to fit that
our pepperonis were
cubed were they not well so
they weren't circular in high school
there was cubed pepperoni on triangular
pizza
which i also got in
in elementary school it was cheese pizza
with no pepperoni on it
it was just cheese pizza excuse me but
then in high school
oh just cheese no pepperoni in in
in uh elementary school dishes in high
school
they added that middle thing or like
sophomore year
the island that had burgers chicken
chicken sandwiches
oh yes which is when i i put
my shoe in there or betsy patrick's shoe
in there i can't remember
what happened yeah uh and
uh triangular pizza with
cubed pepperonis i like that i don't
know um did you eat any of the pizza at
school
no what did you eat in high school i
brought my lunch
every day i'm pretty sure
i mean high school yeah i'm pretty sure
i don't think i brought my lunch ever
in high school yeah i had to have my
pudding cup i was like
i'm in high school now i'm kind of
becoming an adult
it's time it's time to stop bringing
your lunch i don't think that school
pizza would stand
up now but boy i'd really like to taste
it just to know what it
just how good if if it could be as good
as it was to me back then
now it seems like this should be a like
a line in the freezer section
like school pizza just lean into it
but make it taste good it's a good idea
right so it'd be square pizza
what else would you have just that
square just that let's just call it
school pizza yeah
and it's square and there's cheese of
course and
there's a couple of different flavors
and it's uh yeah it's uh
there's a cup of pudding in there too
can we do that
i know yes nobody wants that yeah we can
um staying with school jamie mitchell
naragan
tweeted parachute day in gym class yes
elementary school yeah you know coach
elsie would break out
the parachute and it was you know
that was that was something where
how did the parachute become a thing you
know is it i mean was it that like
parachutists would just i guess they
would just abandon their parachutes and
then
or there was a there was just too many
parachutes around so then they started
figuring out ways to use him in pe class
do you think he had the parachute at all
times or do you think it was like
carried from school to school no he yeah
well he had a nice storage
area yeah storage room but all the
members of the class would grab the
parachute and you put a ball
in the middle and you flap that thing
and to make the ball go up and then we
am i correct in that two things first of
all
i remember there being a hole in the
middle
playing a game where you would you would
throw it up
you would fluff it up and when it was in
the air
you would you would run underneath you
wouldn't run underneath
you pick it up you designate a person to
run underneath pull it behind you and
sit down
and you'd all be underneath and
everybody would be underneath it to be
like we're in a room
in a room but wasn't there a game where
it's like they would choose someone to
run across
and get to the other side maybe yeah boy
that was i
watched a youtube video that was
a giant parachute it was like
um hundreds of people
doing one of these things it's not a
real parachute it was just one that was
designed for
like popping up a ball what were they
doing with that no no they were just
doing it really high and getting
underneath it it makes you feel small
in a good way how often do you how how
often do you think parachute
day happened i think it was twice a year
yeah it was like it was wow it was
special when it came out why why was it
so
that's what that's why i don't think i
don't think it was in storage i don't
know i think you might have bad
information
i think it would be like well it's irwin
today it's in lillington today it's
undone today we got one parachute for
the county
but i think we would know we would
associate the parachute with a parachute
person
but i don't recall any parachute person
showing up when the parachute was there
well the parachute guy drops off the
parachute before you get to school i
think it's
more about how if you play with that
parachute
four days in a row you discover that
like oh we're not really doing anything
this is kind of this actually sucks
yeah but when it's once or twice a
school year
it's special but he
coaches a new one to take it away and he
knew when to bring it back
well but it just followed jamie says
followed closely by scooter day and now
the scooters that uh
are pictured here are these basically a
plastic
platform with handles and four wheels
i i remember the wheels are like casters
that you would that you would
put underneath very this is a very like
a speaker cabinet
very dangerous toy i don't remember this
we didn't have these
i i know i've seen these before but i
don't think i've ever been on one and we
definitely didn't have them wouldn't
that mess up the gym
floor i guess you would do that outside
and do this on the concrete
and you would kind of it was kind of
like a
is it rollerbla not rollerblade roller
nuts
uh sitting skate it was like a sitting
skate but a much
more rudimentary design i don't know
what you're talking about
i don't i don't remember this jamie we
didn't have those
in at bowie's creek elementary school um
i've got one
flat top haircuts flat top haircuts
we'll just
just go and just go into the military
well they were really now i had one
yep you had one for a while and uh
rudolph blanchard would cut it in
and then basically it's all it's like a
buzz that's about
that short like almost bald in the
middle and of course it they make up for
it by being a little bit
higher on the sides and then he would
give you this thing that you put one of
your fingers through
uh like a a comb a plastic cone that
would fit in the palm of your hand
and go over one finger and he would be
like and you got to keep it up you got
to keep it up
i don't remember him giving me any
product for it
but you know i never had that haircut
but i remember the comb
you never had a buzz until until college
like high school when we started cutting
each other's hair in height you did a
buzz in high school
yeah it's funny this is something that
i've noticed
when i kind of go back to the south um
there is a sort of a thing and it was
very common when we were coming up but
it's just like
you shave all the boys heads like if you
if you like
if there's a family with a bunch of boys
in it just for simply just everybody's
got a shaved head
and like we did that
for we had buzzes for years on end
do you remember the buzz days like me
and call both had buzzes
buzzes or flat tops like flat top was as
you're talking about
strategically yeah yeah and the funny
thing is is
my wife would never have let that happen
to my boys
and i know it's like a generational
thing but like
she was always interested in them just
having hair not they never asked for a
buzz
it was it was the style though it was
i mean but if you go back to the south
there's still kids that just have buzzes
she's like yeah he's got a buzz yeah at
this
at this point in time in those in that
environment
i think it's just you know it's just to
simplify things
now i i why do you miss it well i bring
it up because i want to present this as
a
i want to present this as a question to
you yeah um
okay so at some point i'm going to cut
my hair
right now listen this could be
it could be five years from now i'm not
saying i'm gonna just let it grow i am
gonna
i've already trimmed it once i'll
probably trim it again it's getting
to be kind of out of control i'm gonna
try to like get it a little bit closer
but it for the foreseeable future i plan
on having some sort of long haircut
right
but i'm not going to have it forever you
got to make a bold hair choice
and the question is whether it's a year
from now two years from now five years
from now
i have to go back to something i have to
go to something i have to transition
from this to something else
and i've talked to jesse about this i
was like
i think when i and she gets so mad
i was like i think when i get rid of
this hair i'm going to buzz it
i was like i don't think that i'm going
to try to cut it into a haircut
i think i'm going to buzz it and maybe
i'll be like
huh the buzz works you know you're not
going to get rid of your beard you feel
like you're going to die with a beard no
no i'm not getting rid of myself you're
going to die with a beard the only
reason i wouldn't know that's a big
factor in this the only reason i would
get rid of my beard is
if i was trying to like if i become
so committed to like a spiritual
discipline of
detachment that would be the proof would
be in that pudding it would be
because it would be a pizza it would be
difficult for me to deal with my
unshaven face because
i'm ashamed of it yeah that's that's the
real but maybe so maybe i'll get to some
spiritual level where
i i i that's what i do but no
i'm talking about still having a beard
and i've never had that combo
buzz with big beard it might be a good
look well
flat tire i think there's going to come
a day flat top
again if the beard gets bigger the beard
is not good the beard can't get any
bigger than it did
but yeah but if it got because it starts
getting if it got that
big i think you could i mean your hair
is kind of pulled back it you're kind of
simulating something which has the
the shape of a buzz it actually would
not
feel that much different it wouldn't
so what do you think about it i like it
i like the idea oh you like it
i think you should go with flat top like
owen wilson and
that's what i'm feeling and bottle
rocket big beard and like a
guile flat top i mean owen wilson's flat
top
in that movie wes anderson's first movie
bottle rocket
is it's pronounced it's like a two and a
half inch tall
it's got some guile qualities to it my
hair might not support
no i don't think it would my hair's too
curly and it wouldn't it wouldn't be you
need that to be real tight and real
uniform but a buzz
anybody can support a buzz yeah my wife
would hate it she would
hate it i actually don't again
when the hair's pulled back it's not
that much different you know what i'm
gonna do there is gonna be a day
when i'm gonna i'm gonna grow a beard
i'm gonna grow a big beard and it's you
know and i'm gonna get glasses
i know you're gonna you're not gonna get
rid of your beard but i want to have a
total beard at some point but um
it it makes because it's so white it
makes me look so much older
i'm not ready to do it but well
the longer you wait the more white it'll
be well yeah but it'll be like um
you know like like a letterman's beard
like it's
white and huge and then he has no hair
on his head of course he's going he's
bald
but i could uh i could do a i could do a
bus
yeah i i actually had big ho i had high
hopes big hopes
for having a like a really big beard
but the terminal length of the middle of
my beard
i reached it and it just grows on the
side and it becomes a giant
unwieldy square and i'm just like okay
that's it yeah max beardly i want to see
what
what would happen to mine i don't i
don't i don't know
but i don't i don't miss a flat top i
don't miss any of the haircuts i ever
had
none of them at no point and no point
but you only had like
you only had two haircuts before this
one lifetime
yeah well you're the same haircut all
through
elementary school basically and then
it's all chronicled in the book of
mythicality if you want to go back to
that
sweet peach candy at passionate candy
responded to us i wish i could bring
back some of the 80s cartoons
they were some of the best from gem to
she-ra to thundercats
saturday mornings were awesome
thankfully i can re-watch all my
favorites to remind myself and relive
the nostalgia
um so that's saturday morning cartoons
and then somebody she mentioned
thundercats marcus nordberg
also mentioned thundercats i wish they
would make a new movie with thundercats
great content noise with a nice
wholesome lesson at the end to sum it
all up now
in an ad read that we did i mentioned
thundercats
and how i thought it should come back i
don't know if i planted this thought
amongst the mythical beasts but
i watched the first episode of
thundercats like i just put it on
recently recently yeah like a couple
weeks ago was it awful
well it it starts off really interesting
like the pilot episode like the origin
story of
lionel he's a he's like
he's a he's a teen he's like a pr he's a
preteen he's a
he's like pre-pubescent boy
and he's any and he's in this
futuristic environment where all these
like anthropomorphized cats
or are walking around and
defending their fortress against this
these evil people
but all of the cats that you that you
grow to love that are like the key
characters of thundercats
they start off in the pilot episode
naked
naked now i say naked because when you
picture
or google any of the thunder cat
characters
they have suits they have suits on
but when i watch the pilot episode i'm
like oh my gosh they are
there well they're cats but they don't
have any clothes on
and they're walking around like humans
and there is what is it a bulge what is
it there's the
well there's the there's the the leopard
woman
who like has this like these sexy curves
and she i mean she looks like you know
like jennifer lawrence in the x-men
movies when like she's just blue and
she's basically naked except without
nipples
i have no idea what you're talking about
i've never thought about that
i've never dwelt on it nevertheless
jennifer long never picture it yeah of
course never picture it in the quiet
moments
me neither right me neither so i don't
know i'm basically making this up yeah
it's just like a position
in your mind i've heard from someone
if i would have caught it in my mouth
such dirty old man that would have been
amazing
listen i'm watching this with my family
i'm like making them watch thundercats
and i'm like
the first thing i'm i'm like they're
naked that
leopard woman is she's naked and she
doesn't have nipples
that that's the best way i can describe
it that's the most accurate way i could
describe it exactly like
yeah and they knew it too because like
i mean she was strutting her stuff and
at one point
she winks at the camera she knows what's
up she winks at the camera
and then
through a series of events they get
close like this is part of their origin
story
but it's not like they they were already
fully their characters they just didn't
have clothes
but then they were given clothes but for
a while there they are all naked
was it established who gave them the
clothes or they showed up i can't even
remember that
once they once they got closed i stopped
watching it was like this isn't
interesting so it's like
yeah i mean there may be it doesn't hold
up
once they get close but before that it
is pretty exciting
um i don't think it should come back i
think that first half of the pilot
episode is all you need but here's the
thing is that
when you talk about television and just
like passionate candy has pointed out
here
you can get it to come back just by
watching it again like that's the
wonderful thing about media but the
saturday morning cartoon experience is
something that
kids these days don't have like i
remember i remember i would have to get
up
early enough to make sure i didn't miss
smurfs
well it's what john bailey is talking
about here at bayley baileyjohn75
appointment television back in the day
we had a weekly schedule of our favorite
shows friday was tgif tuesday was the
office etc
now we just binge uh
a season in a week so
and this i mean this guy john is
significantly younger than us because
he's talking about appointment
television
and he says the office like we were
adults when the office came out
but but when the office did first come
out it was oh
you had to watch it you know you had uh
tuesday on nbc
and oh yeah and i remember i remember
when lost first came out and i was
you know i was working as an engineer at
the time and that's
like you would watch it because that's
what everyone would be talking about at
lunch the next day it's like that
classic
water cooler conversation like that
literally happened to me
every week there was a we had a water
cooler you would stand at it and you
would have a conversation
about lost well there's a polar bear and
on my island i can't explain that i
don't know what's going on right they
won't
and it was i mean it was a big
motivating factor of just
of going to work just so you because i i
had something i'd watched that now i
could talk about it well
this made me think about i mean you know
we're never going back to this place
right
i mean now that this is just not going
to happen unless the unless the bottom
drops out technologically speaking or
are we i mean like the way that disney
plus is releasing
all of their series i mean i mean like
we made an appointment
to watch the mandalorian and juan
division and you know
every week we look forward to those that
is you know
i do think that that's part of the
philosophy behind why hbo
hasn't strayed from the once from the
weekly release and disney plus is doing
it
is that you know the conversation around
one division
lasted you know yeah it did the duration
of season one
so there is there is definitely strategy
but i think that the product that you're
selling has to be good enough
to be able to compete without being
binge game of thrones
yep um but it made me think about
not just appointment television but
going all the way back to our childhoods
where it wasn't
just this is when the shows are coming
on and you watch them or you don't
but just the number of channels and like
i'm talking 80s i'm talking
basically three channels and pbs maybe
yeah like i remember i feel like i
remember maybe i don't i feel like i
remember when fox
became a channel or when we first got it
because all i remember was nbc cbs and
abc
and pbs and
i was thinking about this in the context
of
our society and one of the things that
people have talked about is
one of the things that's contributing to
the high level of polarization is
everybody gets their
news from their own source right yeah
and back in the day it was like well if
walter cronkite said it you believed it
and that was the only source
there are definitely times when we
didn't watch walter
we watched dan rather dan rather sam
donaldson yep
uh you know samsung broke off sam
donaldson
will he he makes appearances on uh
news now really i know i've seen dan
rather
make well dan rather is like still
totally with it
and making funny tweets yeah he's like
he's in the conversation he'll be a
guest but sam donaldson who
even when he retired his eyebrows were
already he's like a muppet
doing incredible things in the best way
possible yeah they're doing
even more unspeakable things now oh
really
and uh yeah i don't know i can't
remember who he'll he'll come on and
talk to somebody
one of these anchors but anyway it just
makes me think about
boy the simpler times of a
not caring at all about the news and
then if you didn't care about the news
you all cared about the same news
and when i missed that when you came oh
yeah and when it came to television
shows you watched stuff that you didn't
like because
you had to watch something i you know
what and i think that changed
everything for us again i don't want to
be the old fart
who says uh we're this generation and
back in my day
but one of the things i do think is that
our options for what we could watch were
so few
that it kind of transferred over into
everything that we could experience like
even when we think about what
we're going to eat as a family you know
i'll be like you know my dad would just
say we're going to the mexican
restaurant
in fuquay verena it wasn't like yeah
where do you guys want to eat i mean yes
you got to make a decision what you were
going to eat once you got there they
didn't order for you
but where you were going to eat and when
you were going to eat
was not a family conference but
now everything's a family conference and
you know you got you
you've got kids who have been given
you've been empowered to the point that
they can make all these choices and
they're like well i don't i don't like
that and
i don't like that and i don't like that
and i don't want that well we don't want
to watch that just sitting down to try
to watch a movie together
like what is your process for making a
decision
or suggesting a family movie because
that has gotten
i've given up that's gotten out of hand
in my family sometimes that's why we
only watch survivor
like i mean because nobody's tired of it
and there's
more and more seasons and it's it's
there's no conversation you just keep
the only conversation is that we gonna
watch another one or not well i've
i've had some success with choosing
family movies
but there's a lot of pressure and i feel
like they
they believe me that i ca but there was
one what was it what what what did i
oh i uh we had watched uh tombstone
right yeah and so everybody was on board
for tombstone
great movie holds up kids loved it next
night
wyatt earp no it didn't go wyatt earp i
went too hard i went all the way to
unforgiven
that's um clint eastwood unforgiven like
one of his
later i mean well he's been around
forever but that's a great movie but
it's a little
more intense isn't it no what's wrong
with it
uh well i'm trying to remember what
ended up happening
i think we ended up getting through it
but
morgan freeman and clint eastwood it's
an incredible movie
is it slow is it i can't remember what
what could be bad about it
it's just well i mean tombstone is like
real funny and a little bit more
lighthearted i'm forgiven is just a
little bit i mean it starts
out with you know
like the woman's face getting cut up and
stuff it's like oh oh yeah
you know i don't i don't remember it
starts out a little rough
so they they uh they lost
i lost their trust but what i'm saying
my hope my point is
is that when my dad came home
with a vcr first of all he came home
with the vcr
he ran like he didn't buy the vcr he
rented the vcr
and the vhs tapes and walked in the door
and i was like
i don't care what he has he has a vcr
it's a movie in our house we have a
movie in our house this
is the peak of society is what i was
thinking
and it didn't matter what movie was we
we played and he would rent
two movies run it for two days right
watch one one night watch one the next
night two best nights in my life
uh boy my kids are much harder to please
you know when you're talking about like
linear programming and if you miss it
you miss it like even if you
if you really had to go to the bathroom
during seinfeld it's like you would miss
something
you couldn't get it back you'd have to
ask somebody
about you'd have to infer that part
somebody called you on the phone and you
didn't screen it
you know you'd miss that part of it some
people did record
on on the vhs i mean you told me that
your father-in-law
oh yeah he was he was still using a vcr
to record soap operas as recently as
like
two years ago yeah i think he i think he
still does even now
oh really yeah i think he does
i guess he don't want to be he don't
want to be in the house during the day
but you know we were talking about doing
some sort of like we have so much
content
we've tossed around the ideas come up a
number of times of doing like
a channel a mythical channel that's just
constantly playing and you can go in
there
and watch it with whoever's
watch whatever's playing at that moment
with whoever else is
is watching well if you if you took like
you just have every good mythical
morning
every good mythical more 24 every ear
biscuit
every sketch every short form thing
everything we've done on instagram
tick tock whatever and you just put it
back to back to back to back to back
i mean how much content would that be
before it repeated itself
the problem is at least a month from a
business standpoint i think it would be
fun
but from a first of all it would be a
difficult technical exercise well to
answer your question
how long would it be i think jacob did
something where it was like if it was
just good mythical morning
i mean we could do the math right quick
even if we say 10 minutes an episode
times let's just go ahead and say 2 000
episodes
that's um 20 000 20 000 minutes
divided by 60. is
six will go into it's three three
thousand it's three thousand
three thousand hours that doesn't make
sense i think that's right
we just didn't know it's a little over
three thousand hours
no that sounds crazy i can't do math in
my head right now well you
use your calculator okay
but from a business standpoint we can't
you know there was
we couldn't justify it you know it's
like there's a lot of trouble to make
that happen
i think it would be cool oh i think you
might be thinking 300
333 hours so we were off by a factor of
10.
uh but divide that by 24. so it's two
weeks 14 days
13 points so two but that's just gmm and
also you're underestimating the average
length of an episode and then you add in
good mythical mores and you basically
double that
that's a month and then you throw in
everything else you're gonna get at
least a week of stuff that we've done
else
maybe i don't know maybe half a week
yeah yeah we got at least a month of
content
and you rerun stuff the reason that i
still think that it might be
not that bad of an idea is because
you can the whole idea of
of a of linear viewing of anything is
the connection between other people who
are experiencing at the same time
right so it's just like hey we go to the
website where they're
streaming the mythical show mythical
show would be on there too
the mythical tv channel and uh
then you go in the chat room and you
talk you talk about it in a moment like
oh
this is the old thing they did a long
time ago i forgot all about it
i still think there's something to it
now that we're talking about it i think
people are going to ask for it
yeah i mean there's there's kids
channels on youtube that then take all
of they get millions of views on their
videos and then they just make this
live stream that's this this kind of and
they do it because they want to be able
to
parents want to be able to put their
kids in front of something that is
passive for
you know a longer period of time i don't
know maybe we should think about it some
more
okay kina or kenna
having sleepovers with my best friend
and laughing
all the time dang man i mean
i i miss that like i mean would it be
weird
if i was like hey i'm can i come over
tonight we're gonna
like can we we can just sleep on the
couches in your
in your living room yeah it would be
yeah
it would be weird if you did that at my
house too but i'm trying so it's not me
that's weird it's the
it's the act and i just want to i just
want to clarify what is i'm trying to
figure out
why do people why do friends stop
sleepovers
because like as a kid part of the whole
idea of a sleepover is
we're gonna stay up late you know
you don't want your parent to have to
come pick you up late or whatever
there's a sense of adventure
waking up in the morning i mean why
don't friends
adult friends i mean i know that adult
friends like inside friends like john
mayer sings about
are doing sleepovers i'm not talking
about sexual partners i'm talking about
platonic friendships as adults
well when you have land sleepovers i'm
not talking about like hey man can i
crash here i'm talking about hey friday
night
sleepover how come that doesn't happen
maybe it does happen with
with single friends but like if you have
a partner if you have children in the
house it's like you know it's associated
with kids
and then it starts you're telling me
that you think that single people
without children are planning sleepovers
as adult friends right now i haven't
heard of it
i don't think i didn't want to yeah that
should be a thing
you set up a little fort yeah and see
that's where it gets to be like a kid
though
where are you going to sleep hey that's
what it is the adult body
needs a bed needs their own bed that
they're familiar with
when you're a kid i could sleep on a on
a gym floor
i i could sleep anywhere i could sleep
in a chair i could sleep on a fence
it gets i mean whenever i would sleep
over at your house
i gave you a nice mattress you would
give me you had a mattress underneath
your bed and you would pull that out and
i would sleep on that
or sometimes we would both sleep in the
guest room
and because we had there was a couch and
a mattress in there
maybe you'd move the mattress i would
also just put a sleeping bag on the
carpet and sleep
it was it was not a problem but what so
what would we do now because it
yeah it is difficult when you're like
well i'm gonna you know what it's
getting i'm kind of sleeping i'm gonna
go to my bed
with my wife and okay well i'm going to
lay on the floor by you and
jesse or vice versa you know it's like
well i'm just going to sleep on your
computer
sleeping bag and sleep next to us yeah
that's what you do no i think we would
both need to sleep
in the living room in a different room
together
you can't sleep in your own bed yeah i
don't think this is going to happen and
i think we discovered why i mean i've
got it
it's the comfort of your own bed adults
value that too much
why am i going to sleep on the floor
even if it's 3 a.m
it's not working i'm gonna go driving
home i'm gonna go back home and get my
bed i don't want to wake up at your
house
yeah that's strange that's exactly what
it is
and then you wake up in the morning and
then you're like oh
we eat breakfast together like what what
happens now
you know yeah you don't want that well
what what i was thinking we should talk
ourselves into it
i mean if you're we could do a vlog
about it for sure with your
again with when you're when your kids
come downstairs
and like you and your best friend are
like asleep on the couch
just kidding but if you're single
single friends should be sleeping over
what this is a movement we i mean
we can do it for them are we missing
something
i think air matters air mattresses you
know air mattress
so it's i mean a lot of single people
they'll have like another bed
might have a guest bed it may that's not
that's not a sleepover if you're not
sleeping in the same room sleeping in
the same room
the second part of this is in laughing
all the time and what i think i think
you keena you may not necessarily be
putting these two things together but
i'm
assuming i'm taking that that's how i'm
interpreting this because
oh yes that's the part of the sleepover
it's my
you know sleepover making each other
laugh
not being able to shut up having my dad
come up the stairs to get mad at us
because we were so loud because we
wouldn't stop laughing about something
like yeah but that's that level of
laugh attack that's also a difficult
thing too difficult thing to
attain as an adult well you know that's
where alcohol comes in
okay drunk sleepover
yeah i mean we're adults okay
right i mean going going on a trip
somewhere like getting an airbnb
with your friend or friends that's a
sleepover that's still acceptable
because no but but you sleep in
different rooms
but that is that is a form of a
sleepover i i i insist on this coming
back
it's just you got to remove the stigma
you know keep the keep the plutonic
nature intact
but get rid of the stigma sleepovers
hey kids rhett's sleeping over tonight
we're going to be i got a big couch in
there
hey it's an open invitation okay
you're thinking about it well yeah well
you know we'll we'll consider it
tell us what you think about it um but i
really like this one this one this one
has sort of a
feel to it from lynn ljco621
okay late summer night sitting under the
street light with your neighborhood best
friends
discussing the universe life and how you
would be friends forever
not knowing that life would make most of
you drift apart and catch you
up in the rat race of adulthood
to be young again hmm well you know i
mean
i don't mean to rub it in limb but
that's kind of what we're still doing
uh i'm sorry you don't have that but i
mean
i definitely remember when we would have
sleepovers
we would go out and we would lay down in
the pitch dark we would lay down in the
middle of the street on the
like the paved road in front of my house
so few cars would come down the road at
night
that we would lay down in the middle of
the road just because it was a funny
thing to do
i remember that our neighbor came
outside when he saw us
like walking around outside in the dark
and he was like
link you okay
have you been drinking no i don't
remember this yeah and i was like no no
no no we're just
hanging out outside yeah that's what we
hadn't been drinking
but uh he was kind of he was patrolling
us yeah
and christie and and do not try this at
home
yeah don't lay out in the street if we
lived on you know
if a car came you lived on a super super
i mean i lived on a dead end but you
lived on a country road that
the cars were flying but you could hear
them coming from a mile away
literally and um yeah we just get out
there
and there were no street lights first of
all no it was pitch black
or it was just the moonlight and you'd
lay right on the double yellow line
and you just felt like the road was
still warm
yeah there was just something about that
lying in the middle of the road which
you knew was like if any men in a car
could come
and i'm just gonna be looking up into
the sky
yeah there's just something there's
something to that living in a place
where you can lie in the middle of the
road
yeah you know there's just that yeah
it's like
i guess i could lie in like the
neighborhood street in front of my house
but yeah i live on a date somebody would
call somebody
you can i mean if i walked outside and
saw my kid
one of my kids and his friend laying in
the middle of the cul-de-sac i'd be like
i get it yeah yeah i'll be back inside
are sleeping over with my adult friend
you guys been drinking
yeah man saturday morning cartoons what
do you remember watching
i remember smurfs i remember
uh there's a show called shirt tails
they had they had like they had little
stuffed animals that you get at hearties
if it was if it was worth watching it
was worth having its own little thing at
like the hardy's version of a happy meal
california raisins had a cartoon but i
didn't watch that
i did watch the gummy bears cartoon oh
yeah
yeah yeah i watched that i watched the
care bears cartoon yeah
yeah yeah that was a bit was it on one
channel or
or did multiple channels have saturday
morning cartoons uh
for a while all three had saturday
morning
did you choose a channel or did you
switch
i don't remember there's a mr t
cartoon that was i liked that a lot and
then at a certain point they would
switch over to being live
action so you would get i mean you get
like to save by the bells of the world
and
that's when did you stop getting up
early to watch saturday morning cartoons
uh i don't remember
i just i don't i don't remember losing
interest
but i did i definitely was not getting
up in middle school
um yeah i don't think so i was sleeping
until like one o'clock
by the time i was like in seventh grade
yeah because at that point you stay up
late yeah
i don't know that was nice to go down go
down memory lane man
get yourself some animated gummy bears
get that taste in your mouth
thanks for your uh your responses to
that prompt
uh you know keep the conversation going
on the internet hashtag earbiscus
i got a wreck though oh yeah that's my
recommendation it got
um i'm gonna go back to music for for
this recommendation
um i i watched well i guess i'll
recommend the documentary too i watched
the bee gees documentary
um it's on hbo 96 on rotten tomatoes
uh how can you mend a broken heart
is the name of it it it doesn't talk
about their personal lives
as much as just enough to for it to be a
backdrop to the music
so it is a music-centric documentary
it's not
it doesn't talk about i don't know the
drug use or
or you know it goes into i mean it was
three brothers
and then two of them died and well there
were four brothers
but the youngest brother uh was not a
member of the band until
much later he was kind of like
grandfathered in no pun intended but
um they're all dead except for barry
who's arguably the the most recognizable
bg or the beard long-haired yeah
but i i just the documentary is great if
you're into
music documentaries like i am and the
way you know there's so many fascinating
points in their career like that the
fact that they completely
reinvented themselves and the what you
know is the beegees
first and foremost like the defining
sound of the disco era and like that
falsetto voice
is something that they discovered as
like a second wind in their career
and i just i'd love those type of
stories in the specifics of how they
discovered that sound
um with that song jive talking
and then but they did when they released
it to the radio stations
they didn't put they didn't they didn't
put their name on it
because they didn't want people to
associate it with the bee gees because
the bee gees were associated
with like they came out of the beatles
era and they were you know they were
associated with kind of like
this folksy movement and they had a lot
of hits
from from that era but then they were
they kind of had a stigma that then
where they were basically
inventing and defining what disco would
sound like
before it got crapped on um
yeah they didn't they didn't want to use
their name so they they
and it became a hit and they were like
whoa that's that is that's the same bee
geez like
they're singing in another register this
is totally different what did they say
that they were
um they just like unbanned unnamed i
they didn't put the name
on the record they didn't i don't think
they used a pseudonym as far as i can
remember from the documentary they just
didn't say
it was just like jive talk and play it
um and then they were playing it before
they knew it was the biggies and then
deciding that they loved it but the one
song that i'm obsessed with
because there's a stigma around the bee
gees in in like uh the disco era
and like they get into that they explain
all that too
and how they were brought down but they
didn't deserve it
and people like justin timberlake are in
the documentary standing up for the bee
gees rightfully so
and i just i had not intentionally
avoided them
but i just had i had missed all these
amazing
harmonies and like and their
their melody structures are just like
so enticing but the one song that i'm
obsessed with is too much heaven
too much heaven listen to that song and
if you like it then you can watch the
documentary but
it's just so sweet man
it it is sweet well if you want some
sweet tunes
tune into too much heaven from the bee
gees
and we'll catch you next week on another
episode of
ear biscuits to watch more ear biscuits
click on the playlist on the right
to watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]